Los Seguidores de hezbolla celebran que
su líder hassanna rala tomó las riendas
de la situación anunció que un buque
iraní con combustible zarpará hacia el
Líbano y advirtió a sus enemigos que no
intenten intervenir hasta fin
la embarcación proveniente de Irán
zarpará en las próximas horas
a los estadounidenses e israelíes les
digo es territorio libanés
narrada aseguró que el cargamento será
el primero de muchos sin embargo la
entrega violan las sanciones que Estados
Unidos impone a Irán y los opositores
ajes volá alertan que esto puede
implicar sanciones para Líbano un país
en bancarrota
el estado libanés no puede permitirse
importaciones en sectores clave y
después de que el Banco Central cortará
los subsidios al combustible la escasez
de luz ha empeorado y ha desencadenado
el cierre de oficinas hospitales y
negocios
no tengo gas para el horno no tengo
electricidad para hacer pan en la sartén
he tenido que tirar todas mis
provisiones Qué debo hacer horas después
del anuncio de la presidencia libanesa
aseguró que Estados Unidos suministrará
electricidad desde Jordania y
combustible desde Egipto organizaciones
internacionales han prometido cientos de
millones de euros en ayuda al Líbano si
sus políticos logran formar un gabinete
estable que reforme el país algo que
todavía tiene que suceder